nous
réglons ça tout de suite minestrone est
un mot masculin cela dit le ministre
veuille se cuisine très bien au féminin
avec nos deux invités maria et patricia
c'est un report et confortant qu'on
mange surtout à l'automne en hiver
anciennement c'était des recettes de
pain on dirait p aujourd'hui c'est notre
cousine santé
qu'est ce que ça représente 7 du chlore
dans votre vie ça représente les repas
en famille
repas d'automne avec tous les produits
qu'on avait su la faire en italie chaque
région a sa version du ministre mais
elles ont toutes un ingrédient comme une
chose qui est toujours là présente ce
sont les animaux maria a fait trempette
15h ses bords de l'authie appli ici avis
qu'au québec on peut mettre beaucoup de
champs dans un ministre on est souvent
oliva aussi avec qu'est ce qu'on a dans
le réfrigérateur
il ya des carottes des tomates du céleri
et l'oignon très important ça donne du
goût on va le faire revenir dans un peu
d'huile une feuille de laurier
oui la pompe de tej et que s'est
procurée chaud non non le matin
évidemment ça va prendre du liquide oui
ça peut être de l'eau ça peut être un
bouillon de légumes - les mots bouillon
de poule de maison les gens qui aiment
s'applique à et peuvent eux-mêmes eux
déposé un petit
[Musique]
il faut remonter à l'an 30 pour trouver
des traces d'une somme pouvant être
l'ancêtre de cette soupe repas
bouillon légumes haricots et un peu de
cervelle
maria a retrouvé cet autre recette de
temps de la rome antique la tisane à
barika dit ah pis y'a donc c'est la
première
souhaitait ferro naamé 1,7
beaucoup de légumineuses du lard des
points rouges du chou et de l'eau et
comme assaisonnement hi fi ns herbe et
ce aux poissons
j'ai hâte de goûter
bien potentiel
la base est là et à des bons produits ce
très nourrissant oui
quand on connaît pas ça ne manque pas
donc
d'installer ses surnoms excellence au
deuxième busherie meilleure première oui
aux habitués le goût comme on voit pas
de tomates pas de pommes de terre ni de
nuit dans cette recette parce que ça
n'existait pas en italie à cette époque
c'est au tour de l'an 1400 que les
échanges commerciaux avec l'asie
permettre l'arrivée des pâtes
alimentaires en europe et c'est
seulement au milieu du xvième siècle que
tomates et pommes de terre traverse
l'atlantique pour terminer dans
l'assiette des européens d'ailleurs dans
la recette de patricia il n'y a pas que
thomas moi ce que j'aime bien et mettre
ses des pommes de terre des carottes des
courges et sellerie des oignons jeu mais
aussi la fin de ta pour donner un petit
coup extra juin des parts mais les
portes on peut les remplacer par du ray
on peut les remplacer par de l'orge de
l'ip autres et puis je mets des fins de
parmigiano reggiano c'est ça on a
tendance à les acheter mais croûte de
partie
jamais jamais faut jamais acheter ça on
est là on les utilise dans n'importe
quelle soupe un minestrone c'est comme
estime on peut manger sopi et envoie
d'ailleurs dans ton assiette ça
oui c'est très très bon
[Musique]
et la voilà notre jour je souhaiterais
que vous ajoutiez un peu de fromage
parmesan ou le pecorino
le ministre on peut aussi se transformer
en ministre a laminé ce tracé une fois
qu'on fait en terminer ce trône et on a
fait toujours plus on en garde le parti
on fait cuire des pâtes courtes et on
ajoute ceux minestrone et là sur les
parts et une ministre a donc c'est
beaucoup moins liquides on ajoute
bompard matin par dessus puis ça fait
notre repas et voilà c'est
ta déposé d'anjou dans le fond ensuite
mettre la soupe par dessus la raison est
simple c'est que si yeux des restants et
puis les parts sont dans la soupe les
peintres ont absorbé tout bouillon
tandis que si on les garde ses paris
mais l'on peut garder la soupe la manger
le lendemain en fait d'autres parts et
puis et puis c'est une toute nouvelle
soupe
[Musique]
je mets au défi des familles qui ont des
enfants qui aiment pas les légumes parce
que dans un minestrone et je sais pas
pourquoi mais les enfants aiment ça
[Musique]
merci sonata famille a toujours été ça
c'est vraiment une recette de ma
grand-mère que ma mère a fait piquer que
moi d'ailleurs je suis pas ça va me
parler après quand avant sa mort que je
vous ai annoncé la grossesse c'est comme
ça qu'on ne se connaît pas bien quelles
fins
[Musique]